but I really watch your career and you
have to watch what you do where you go
they were here I found myself in Ohio
three times in a month and a half I'm
like who booked this who booked this but
you don't lose your booking yeah magic
Cleveland Toledo and Columbus I'm like
maybe they're eight hours apart
people like man we want to see you last
800 for a [ __ ] year and a half like
that's it they don't need to see me you
know I'm saying so I watch I play it out
I don't go to the same clubs every year
I played out 18 months two years you
know and when I sold him that concept or
like that's not gonna work then Ron
White went over to see a angle [ __ ] I
don't do nothing except every 16 months
like I told you really yeah that's not
like the saddest loosen bro there's a
plan they have a plan and you gotta have
a plan if you fall for that plan guess
what if it doesn't work for you you're
gonna be in and out of that machine and
three and a half years you're gonna
carry your luggage for the rest of your
life when you're 50 to these [ __ ]
town yeah [ __ ] you I got an out plan I
got an end plan it's my mother [ __ ]
world mm-hmm and I've taped two weeks a
month I work on this I work on this I'm
trying to write a book you know so all
this [ __ ] tastes time I enjoy doing the
road I still have my fort when I'm in
town I still do for us that's a week
yeah you're only have a goal to do I do
one up in the valley and then I'll do
like two on Tuesday to one Thursday and
one on Saturday and so that's five and
I'm done for the week yeah so I never
burn out and I learned that from a guy
named Joe Rogan mm-hmm because when we
were coming up they put you on the road
every week they don't give a [ __ ] you're
out there with the same jokes and
material what save Joe was he had Fear
Factor and he had news radio so you had
that money so he didn't have to wore
himself out every week he could go out
whenever he wanted to pick his dates if
you know what you don't want to pay me
then you ain't gonna see me because I
got a job here yeah and I was like
that's how you do it so you gotta say no
from time to time to keep them on their
[ __ ] cause you make everyone so why
you got a qalam I got a movie [ __ ] yeah
and they an applet next week what do you
mean you got to keep them on their toes
and know that you don't [ __ ] around
anything can happen in my
world at any time you know yeah I think
you have to be the captain of your own
ship guys just leave it to them no they
know it from a business standpoint but
they don't know from a comic standpoint
our talent standpoint no one like you
know how many comics shows have you seen
I talk to other comics you can't just
keep going back to that saying well it's
gonna tell what works for GSP may not
work for Bend and shop and what works
for Brendon shop yep may not work for
that GSP yeah it's a great point in you
know this is why a year and a half gone
was two years ago probably when people
went what's next for Connor and I went
Floyd Mayweather and what why cuz I put
myself in his shoes on what would I do
what would it if I'm his manager
thinking of complete business kind of
perspective here what would I do Floyd
Mayweather I got nothing to lose I'll
make more money than God the promotion
and publicity I get out there I'll be
the biggest UFC fighter of all time it's
gonna involve the entire boxing
community the entire MMA community if
somehow we can cross-pollinate all this
I'm fighting 145 pound man who's really
not gonna knock me out even if I can
just last 12 rounds even if I get out
class but he goes 12 rounds it's a no
brainer for me or or the office of that
is I fight khabib or I fight Tony
Ferguson these killers make 20% of the
money I'd make fight in Floyd Mayweather
there's me way more damage involved it's
I can be as publicly as big either so I
just put myself and [ __ ] on it it's
Floyd Mayweather man it's a no-brainer
you know another guy that I'm learning
from if you're not taking notes on the
Conor McGregor School of Business you
slip him right yeah whether you like him
or not yeah you slip him right now he's
doing it he's calling his shots he's
disrupting [ __ ] world belts he
disrupt nobody could do nothing
everybody's locked up no five didn't
know what to no 155 and 170 everybody's
locked up he's gonna fight Mayweather he
might come back and fight Nate he's
definitely gonna go for the 170 time
mm-hmm
he started that in New York I showed you
the video he won now yep now he's still
you know he's got the 145 on 155 what's
he gonna do lurk down there with
mosquitos he's already been down that
done he's gonna once that
and that's just cool but every one of
his moves are so thought out and
calculated and calculated and that's a
businessman you know that's and that
applies to anything a musician a plumber
a [ __ ] builder that same train of
thought put lies to a lot of things but
with him Joey don't you think and you're
the same way in road in the same way
don't you be you too and I always say
this but you have to get to that point
it's knowing your worth like Conor
McGregor he knows if he like he did a
press conference you notice he did his
[ __ ] stadium that's sold out in some
of the ticket or $2,500 it's just a Q&A
with him talking [ __ ] about with Lloyd
on yes in Ireland it's all-out stadium
[ __ ] press conference
so he knows his Worth and he can talk
all the [ __ ] to Dana and you're seeing
go this this why I'm doing [ __ ] you
that's why I'm doing if you don't like
it get the [ __ ] on my way and I love it
cuz he knows it's worth the same thing
with you like I'm not gonna [ __ ] Ohio
eat this dick I'm not doing that but oh
yeah I'm not going to Vegas [ __ ] Vegas
but you guys yeah you're in the position
we can do that where they're like [ __ ]
we need a man so right let me do his
thing but for a lot of guys they can't
do that like a lot of UFC fighters if
Dan says jump yes a how hi boss
cuz there's just not there yet you know
I'm saying so I feel like you guys know
your worth I always say that know your
worth but at the same time you have to
get to a certain level before you can
make those demands
it's a tough it's a fine line some exams
you have to make those decisions to get
to the next level but there always is
decisions that you have to say I'm not
going to do they get to that no matter
what you know years ago for three after
that writers strike I wouldn't get calls
for TV or movies guess what I got calls
for YouTube projects yeah for two years
everybody I met for lunch we have this
YouTube project and one day I said come
on do it's like a YouTube type of
[ __ ] the [ __ ] around yeah but
not to do projects on YouTube yeah and I
stopped and the phone kept ringing and
prices kept going up these YouTube web
series and I said no and two days later
I got grudge match
mmm the movie bombed it didn't matter
the state of mind was
Manor decided what was gonna do you know
it's like I've been pitching a show
lately and I looked at the writers
didn't I know you guys did a great job I
want you to know my [ __ ] attitude I'm
not going in there to sell a show I'm
going in there and let these
[ __ ] justify their existence
yeah however you go there's different
levels where you make the decision of
what and what's not gonna happen
listen man you have to be a star to tell
comedy clubs you're not working on a
[ __ ] Sunday and I decided in nineteen
that ass shrug ass Rogan see if Rogan
work Sundays okay I call him up go Joe
do you want to work Sundays cuz dear
straight me to [ __ ] out on Sunday it's
really you got damn right
you goddamn right there's no no reason
to work a Sunday yeah to sit in your
hotel room all day without your family
and then take a plane Monday morning
which is gonna be [ __ ] delayed you
know to do a shelf rights and 200 people
that usually don't go to comedy clubs
and the show's over at 9:00 so now you
miss the red-eye by a [ __ ] pubic hair
you missed the red-eye to LA by a pubic
hair so now you got to land in LA Monday
morning on the 405 at 11:00 your day is
shot the time you get home that'll [ __ ]
you yeah I decided in 1998 in 2000
before a Longest Yard I was giving up
weeks
like people say Wednesday through
Saturday and I go I don't do something
that's Joey then you can't work here
fine and I would hang up the phone and
it had happened for years I remember
telling Joe I would leave Joe in cities
call him up and ask him I'm out call him
up and ask that I would tell him before
we went down there by the way Sunday
mornings you and Ari
what do you mean Joey yeah you supposed
I don't work Sundays I told you that a
long [ __ ] time ago don't even involve
me on a Sunday because before I became a
comic I'm a man yeah and I'll tell you
what you got to eat dinner with your
family on Sundays if not you're not
gonna have a [ __ ] family and I've
seen it that I could sit here rattle off
comics names that don't have a family
because they want to work on [ __ ]
Sundays when you see my back ripple and
I pull myself up like a champ like a
champ through 30 times
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a guess it's a gift
it's a gift